el consejo permanente de la Organización
de Estados Americanos celebrará una
sesión extraordinaria el jueves 20 de
octubre a las 2:30 de la tarde hora de
Washington será en el salón de las
Américas de la oea para considerar la
situación en Perú el mismo secretario
general de la huella Luis almagro en una
carta al presidente del Consejo
permanente le pidió convocar la sesión
extraordinaria del Consejo permanente
para analizar el pedido que le hizo el
presidente castillo de activar los
artículos 17 y 18 de la carta
democrática Interamericana y responder
desde instancias internacionales a la
situación política que vive el Perú
donde el presidente Castillo fue
denunciado constitucionalmente por la
fiscalía de la nación de presuntos
delitos de organización criminal de
tráfico de influencias y corrupción
agravada la reunión contará con las
presentaciones de Edgar estuardo Ramón
Orellana primer presidente y relator
para el Perú en la comisión americana de
derechos humanos y también del ministro
de relaciones de relaciones exteriores
del Perú César Rodrigo Landa Arroyo